joining me now with reaction is Ann
Coulter conservative commentator and
author of resistance is futile
also with me is Alan or immigration and
civil rights attorney and I want to
start with you what recourse does the
Trump administration have in dealing
with migrants that are illegally
crossing the border while trying to seek
asylum well I think maybe having
firearms would be helpful that was
hilarious what they're like British cops
they don't have guns do our troops on
the DMZ have firearms this is this is a
little more important than protecting
South Korea as important as that is it's
our country I mean there are a lot of
things Trump could do if he have to do
if he's not going to build a wall which
apparently he isn't he could go a few
yards into Mexico on have an emergency
military action there but I don't think
it's gonna help with billy clubs well so
Alan I wanted so secretary Kirsten
Nielsen said yesterday that there are
500 criminals in involved or in the mix
of the migrants as well as gang members
I want to play some sound for you for a
former vice director Tom Holman and get
your thoughts on it
take a listen I was called a fear monger
but you know what unfortunately I was
right now we're going to talk more
caravans come and truly put themselves
in the hands of criminal organizations
we're gonna bankroll smuggling
organizations we bankrolled drug cartels
who control the corridors heading to the
border and these people are put at risk
women will be raped people will die
crossing borders children will drown
people will be misused by these criminal
organizations we've seen over and over
again last year-and-a-half family people
have died at the hands of these
criminals so Alan to Mister Homans point
as well as what secretary Nielsen laid
out Arthur real national security
concerns and you know defense concerns
at the southern border right now no I
don't think there's any more concerns in
there right the other border right every
day hundreds of thousands of individuals
apply to enter to this country and
specifically at the Tijuana port at
least a hundred thousand individuals
apply every day so an extra 2,000 or
4,000 for the United States to sort to
see if they are available for entry or
should be turned away should not be a
problem for the United States
so therefore this whole thing is
basically theater political theater
because the caravan has been coming for
years and Ann is actually also said that
on the show and this is the first time
that we've ever deployed actually we
have the National Guard and the troops
at the border for such a small number
but he's not the first president to send
troops to the border President Obama did
that president george w bush president
HW bush he's certainly not the first
president to do that that's not not just
into the border for at this this level
in this number and at this magnitude to
address individuals who are coming here
which i don't even call them the
caribbean I call them survivors because
they're sort of fleeing for their lives
so to meet people who are fleeing for
their lives but guns instead of welcomed
them and using the American laws that
we've all agreed on for Congress to let
them allow to apply for asylum
that's not very American well and it's
not just President Trump and Republicans
that have concerns with what's going on
at the southern border you have the
tijuana mayor wearing a hat saying you
know make tijuana great again you have
mexican protestors out there saying this
is our country and having concerns with
what's happening so what do you make to
what Alan just said well that's the
proof positive that they are not fleeing
for their lives which is why for asylum
you either have to apply in your home
country or you apply in the first
country you come to all of the Mexican
protesters and by the way I mean I guess
it's fun needling the Mexicans for being
hypocrites on illegal immigration but I
don't really care what Mexico's policy
is this is this is our country our
policy should be what Donald Trump ran
on we we're trying to run a country here
it isn't it isn't an international
lounge at JFK but you have to apply
either to the cuttin in the country
you're in or the first country you
that's just factually not correct we
stopped sleep please don't flee stop
saying that you're not in but why aren't
these migrants doing it the right way
why aren't they going to ports of
authority why do you see some of them
breaking the law in illegally crossing
the border if they're truly have a
credible fear threshold that is being
met why not just do it the right way
okay well let's correct the record first
of all you can't apply for asylum in
your home country that doesn't work that
way there is a rule you can of course
the plot to the first country which you
enter court in Mexico who are not
Mexican
in Mexico over the course of the last
couple of months has accepted more
immigrants that they have in the past
they've actually stepped at the numbers
of actually integrating people into
society more than the United States has
so all those things combined with people
who are fleeing for their lives coming
thousands of miles they don't know the
port of entry is right if you've never
been to a city before you don't know
where the port is and continually this
administration has made it hard for
individuals who do appear at the port as
you have seen on Tuesday when the
president closed down the port for no
reason at all but two other sin fear and
then only allowing a couple of families
in at a time
so therefore this concept of them
crossing the border illegally or them
being illegal or them being illegal
aliens when they're not even in the
country really we should stop saying
that
right and so the law allows the
Constitution allows through the
administration Act that doesn't matter
how they enter the country between ports
which we heard from the Ninth Circuit
they're still allowed to apply for
asylum and if we want to change that we
should change Congress well the laws are
also being exploited we know that as a
factory of eighty percent of these
individuals passing their initial
threshold with immigration officials and
then only twenty percent are actually
granted asylum in immigration court so
that is also in fact and I want to get
your take on what Chief Justice Roberts
recently said in criticizing President
Trump and going after the Ninth Circuit
saying we do not have Obama judges or
Trump judges Bush judges or Clinton
judges what we have is an extraordinary
group of dedicated judges your thoughts
on that well I warned the country about
Justice Roberts thought he was a mistake
the one thing I will definitely give
president from credit for is appointing
justices like Kavanaugh and not Harriet
Miers and and Justice Roberts I don't
know why he's jumping into this I have a
lot of complaints with Trump that tweet
was absolutely right I'm glad he's
appointing judges that are enforcing the
law and yes the law is you seek asylum
in the first country you get to you are
by definition not fleeing for your life
when you are trekking through thousands
of miles of other countries and oh well
welfare isn't good enough here in Mexico
I think I'll keep going
the reason they keep going to the US and
the reason it makes a difference where
we set up the troops they should be as I
said if
few yards into Mexico is one Sun on
Mexican steps on US soil we can't turn
them away the idea was to stop human
smuggling when in fact it's done exactly
the opposite it's creating human
smuggling so Mexicans we can turn away
at the border if we catch them that's
why we want her to all anyone who is a
non Mexican who has just walked through
this enormous country not fleeing for
their lives ray for better welfare once
they step on US soil we can't just send
them home we have to give them hearings
these hearings go on and on they just
escape into the country and there you
are
all right well thank you and Alan
appreciate it